hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the world blitz championship
it's a grandmaster Sallisaw I'm
representing United Arab Emirates versus
Magnus Carlsen and we said that we were
gonna cover at least one more game from
from day one of the world with
championship and that we're gonna check
out the standings after the 12 rounds
have been played so it's a it's a really
crazy game and a lot of well it's the
one that was suggested the most by you
guys and for good reasons now just a
heads up I'm going to ask you to pause
the video four times in this video
because the positions that arise are
that interesting now so you know I hope
you don't mind that and I would just
like to thank you for all of the
contributions that you've made regarding
the translations now I I never checked
order any contribution so with
translating my videos not just the
videos you know the subtitles the the
description the titles because I don't
receive notifications for that but I've
checked it yesterday and there were just
a whole lot of them so I've published
all of them so really thank you for that
for for making the channel more
available now to everyone in different
languages I just wanted to mention that
so really thank you guys
now getting to back to the game I saw
solemn Saleh opens with d4 we have
Knight to f6 by Magnus c4 now we have
six Knight to c3 and d5 this is of
course the Queens gambit declined
we have portrayed in the center magnus
recharacterize ECAP force and e5 and the
Bishop to g5 c6
strengthening the center as the night is
now pinned we have III and the Bishop to
d6 by Magnus we have Bishop to d3 and we
have castles Knight G to E - and now
comes Luke t8 we have Queen to c2
putting pressure on h7
so h6 rush up to h4 and now Magnus goes
for a5 preventing any future expansion
bye-bye white but also making room for
the night on a6 Magnus wants to get this
maneuver in night - a6 the C 76 and from
a six the night would be the world the
knight would just be very well placed
with a three by solemn and now comes
Knight to a6 as planned with
a ch3 taking away the G Foursquare from
Carson's pieces and now tonight the c7
going to that six square we have castles
by our salad and now tonight the e6 and
here there are a few games that reach
this position working the King to H one
was played f30 move rook a to d1 is a
known move but the move solid place is a
new move it is f4 and it is as of move
14 that we have a completely new game
now it's a kind of a trade off you do
grab the e5 square although it's it's a
bit different since you don't have the
knight on f3 to immediately place on on
e5 on the other hand your III point is
not a backwards pawn so it's going to be
a little bit weak and Magnus tries to
take advantage of this since he already
has a knight on e6 by playing g5 and
here the way this should be treated is
by simply capturing it captures Knight
captures Bishop captures H captures and
the rook F doom preparing rook a to f1
here white is just perfectly fine
however solid he decides to keep the
bishop pair he plays Bishop to g3 and
now Magnus continues pushing we have g4
and now Russia back to h4 again with the
pin on the knight here we have G
captures an h3 by Magnus and now Knight
the g3 solid plays with some great style
he wants to get his queen over to the
open G file to help out with the attack
and Magnus is not interested in that he
goes Knight to g7 that takes control of
f5 and now comes route 81 here Bishop to
e7
now the knight can move again so if he 4
is played you will also be able to
capture it with the point and the night
we have f5 by solid now cramping across
since position but now cause in place a
very interesting move H to H 2 cannot be
captured if you capture than just Knight
g4 check picks up the bishop on h4
so you have to go back Knight King to H
1 and now Magnus should offer a trade
with Knight to e4 however he decides to
offer it with Knight to g4 and well this
this just doesn't work yes the point is
nicely protected here but this allows f6
this is what solid plays Magnus captures
it okay
you do have a triple defense on f6 so
Magnus just picks it up but this doesn't
work and this is the first moment in the
game where I will ask you to pause the
video and try to find the winning move
for solid well I'll give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who found it
congratulations on successfully adding
another attacker to the f6 square and
for those who just want to enjoy the
show its Queen to f2 and here is the
dets efficient soo so never recapture
automatically because well there just
might be a nice in-between lurking that
we'll just win you the game so here
there is no way to defend you you cannot
add another defender hh5 is covered
you cannot go here to add another
defender to the night and three pieces
are just attacking it so next move
you're just gonna capture the night and
you cannot move the night if you move
the night
well there's that's really no point in
moving the night because just Queen
captures on f7 so here Salih had an
opportunity to win the game but first he
captured an f6 magnus recaptured and now
he played queen to have two now it's a
bit different because now magnus has
rook to east six adding another defender
here so what can be played here Salah
continues with E 4 and we have Queen to
e7 now so if captures Magnus can trade
rooks with rook captures anyone so here
if I've still keeps the advantage for
white but solid decides the capture on
d5 we have rook captures any one for
Magnus rook captures any one and now
there is only one good move for Magnus
here everything else loses the game so
once again feel free to pause the video
and try to find the only good move for
black while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those who were able to do
it congratulations and once again
spotting that you cannot move the Queen
as f6 is being threatened and for those
of you who just want to enjoy a show
it's Bishop captures on d4 with a
counter-attack on the Queen the point is
if you move the Queen rook F 1 again
wins because well you lose the piece or
you move the bishop and f7 falls here
you can defend with 98 but Knight h5 now
becomes possible adding a third attacker
to the bishop and again it's just it's
just a lost piece
so Bishop captures on d4 by Magnus now
you cannot capture otherwise Queen after
sunny one so here a solid goes for the
trade we have rook captures on its on e7
Bishop captures on f2 and now once again
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the best continuation for white
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting yet yet
another edition suit and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
d captures on c6 point being that now if
the game continues as the game continued
you always have pawn captures on b7
which will just be deadly so it was just
just a free pawn to capture Selleck
misses this he goes Knight g4 and it's
not just a pawn that he missed it's it's
a lot more ok crossings Bishop is under
attack now he moves it with tempo
blusher page for attacking the rook we
have looked a five and now for the last
and fourth time or for the fourth and
last time in this video feel free to
pause it and try to find the winning
move for Magnus while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on spotting that the rook does not have
many squares to choose from and for
those of you if you just want to enjoy
the show
f6 wins the game here well it wins
material because the rook has no squares
the D scores are covered by the knight
discovered by the bishop these two
squares are covered by the knight so
only a 7 is available to the Brooks so
rook to e7 was played but now well look
at just the the relationship between the
bishop and the rook Magnus just pushed
f5 and here the rook and the night are
now under attack and there is no defense
against this solid plate rook to c7 but
F captures on e4 magnus just grabs a
piece Bishop to c4 and now C captures on
d4 we have Knight captures on d5 and now
Bishop to e6 magnus counters all of the
nasty discoveries and it was in this
position that saw himself resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here
he's down a piece and also Magnus is
just up two points so this is a it would
be pointless to continue this
so this is again from Route three a lot
of you have suggested it so I do hope
you you all enjoyed it and here I do
have the standings prepared these are
the standings after around 12 so in
first place Magnus Carlsen half a point
a his on 10 out of 12 so half a point
ahead of Maxima Tanaka who is in second
place with nine and a half then with
nine points we have Hikaru Nakamura the
Neal du Bois Indiana pony she would
eight and a half video Gujarati
Vladislav artemiev young she still do
the Sharma media of you young ji and
Giga cooperates then with eight points
barter such PO who has been playing an
awesome awesome blitz tournament pal
Punk rat of alexey dr ali reza Ferrara
also on eight points Dmitry and rake in
Manuel Petrosyan Gabrielle Solis Ian
Timur Gaurav then max impartial a graph
also on it butter Java Vladimir Kramnik
don't know if I mentioned this one Mia
Kramnik briefly came out of retirement
to play out this blitz tournament then
Ahmed oddly max involving elders Safari
and Alexander Grisha again I chose to
show the first 26 so angry shocked will
also be showcased here now but yeah
that's the first day of the world boots
right championship I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank Kirk Mason
Jason Mattingly who quit run glipglop
computer cop chunk of and the Joseph
mature for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos serum thankful for watching and I
will see you soon continuing with the
coverage of the final day of the world
blitz championship so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day